before i go to bed i write down six most  important things i have to do tomorrow  these are goal achieving activities  and when i wake up that's what i start  working on  and if i don't get them all done i'll  add them to tomorrow's list  you should have about six now if i have  three that i didn't get done today that  doesn't mean i have  nine for tomorrow like six plus these  three  those three become part of the six you  have to do the next day  [Music]  when you wake up you give all your  conscious attention to do those things  see you cannot manage time but you can  manage activity  you can manage your activities make  certain that what you're doing really  makes a difference  makes certain that you're spending your  time on  activities that are productive that are  taking you in the direction of your goal